This one. The means are significantly different, because you can see that their
variability within each sample is less. The more variability each sample has
with itself, the less significant the sample mean differences are. The same
goes if we have three or more samples. Remember how we used a sample mean to
construct a 95% confidence interval for the true population mean that the
sample came from? In this case, the true population mean would most likely be
somewhere in here in this interval. And the the true population mean from the
red sample would probably be somewhere in here. It's very, very unlikely that
the true population means will be the same. But in this case, when there's more
variability within the samples, the population mean could be anywhere from here
to here for this blue sample, or here to here for the red sample. Thus, there's
this overlap here, and it's likely that the populations that these samples came
from have the same mean.